and I hereby declare that Valerie Carol
Marian Vaz has been duly elected I would
now like to invite the winning candidate
Valerie about to say a few words
can I start by thanking you mr.
returning officer and everyone who has
been involved in mounting and presiding
over the casting of boats during this
election can I also thank the police for
looking after us and making sure that
democracy wins I also want to thank my
husband Paul Townsend my agent Ian
Robertson and my family and most of all
brilliant volunteers down there who have
helped me win this election they have
worked incredibly hard for the vision
that the Labor Party set out in our
manifesto I also want to pay tribute to
Paul Scheer who is the chief executive
was decided that he wants to retire I
don't know why because he's been an
amazing chief executive of Walsall
council but we wish him well and I want
to thank him for all his years of public
service I also want to pay tribute to my
colleague David Winnick he has been an
outstanding MP representing Warsaw law
he has bounced into the chamber in the
House of Commons every day and really
taken the fight to the government and
opposed things that have hurt his
Dickenson most and I'm sorry I won't be
seeing him sitting on those green
benches thank you David for all the work
that you have done
[Applause]
this result isn't a result just for me
it is a result for the vision that
Jeremy Corbyn and the labor policy set
out what we set out was a positive
vision for Britain that has been
responded to by the voters of wattle
south and I'd like to thank them most of
all for voting for that visions that the
Labour Party has put forward a vision
for young people a vision for those who
work those who are sick vulnerable and
those who are elderly we had a vision
for all stages of our lives so thank you
all once again for voting for me and
once again thank you to the brilliant
unsung heroes behind the scenes who help
so hard and work so hard to ensure the
election of a Labour MP in Walsall south
thank you
[Applause]
you